all right so let's take a look at some
of the delusions that were taking place
at cpac this weekend
now really understand that cpac the
conservative political action conference
put on by the american conservative
union
it used to be mostly like a pretty
standard republican event you know
they would say things i disagreed with
about taxes
uh i wouldn't agree with them on health
care i wouldn't agree with them about
abortion i wouldn't agree about gay
marriage or foreign policy
but it wasn't always a totally nuts
q anon conspiracy type event
cpac appears to now have completely
surrendered
to the most extreme conspiratorial
unhinged elements of the party
essentially like the wackiest of the
pro-trump wing of the republican party
and hilariously a seven-point plan
to reinstate donald trump in days rather
than years
yeah was handed out at cpac
um this you have to see and
interestingly
it does include one point from our story
a few weeks ago
the idea of trump becoming uh
speaker of the house andrew solinder
from forbes tweeted about this
cpac attendee sent me this picture of a
card they were handed
about a seven point plan to restore
donald j
trump in days not years which involves
installing trump as
speaker and ousting biden and
harris so let's look at the plan point
one by the
notice that the first point is
meaningless the first point is
reveal achilles heel pull back
the curtain on the horror show that is
today's democrat party
watch pelosi melt like the wicked witch
of the west
see the black caucus and other key
groups
flip unexpectedly and watch the tables
turn
fraud the second i that one's
meaningless okay
the second item just means they want to
win the next election that's not it's
not really a plan it's sort of like
what political parties do uh number two
is witness a trusted conservative
elected a speaker of the house and
finally
reveal suppressed results of existing
investigations into election
racketeering the second part won't
happen
because they just lost but the first
part is like just win
then they want to correct the official
record and reveal that trump
legitimately won the 2020 election
their fourth part is that the speaker of
the house will draft articles of
impeachment for biden harris
that we know that that's what they want
to do if they win the house in 22.
then they will uh elect trump speaker of
the house now remember we talked about
this some weeks ago
you actually don't have to be a member
of congress to be speaker of the house
traditionally that's the case that's the
way it's been but trump could be made
speaker
without even being a member of congress
then they would have
the speaker of the house trump uh call
for a vote to impeach charge and remove
biden and harris who they refer to as
imposters
and then step seven is duly impeach
charge and remove biden and harris
which you know seems very similar to
item number six
so what's funny is that really the only
two
things here that are a plan would be
item number two which is to win the next
election
and in order to do that one way to do it
would be hey come up with some
substantive policy ideas like win
by offering policy that people like
no they're not doing that uh instead
they're going with option two
which is try to suppress the vote to win
and only talk about things like
communism
and critical race theory or whatever
else they are trying to do that
it didn't work in 2020 they didn't
suppress enough of the vote in 2020
but they came kind of close and so we
have to really
i don't know why i am really worried
about 22 and 24 more than i've been
this far in advance of any recent
election
i think we have to be ready that they
they almost suppressed enough of the
vote
they may do it in 22 and they may do it
in 24.